foreign
hello good morning good afternoon good
evening good whatever the hell
um and welcome to sidetrack
everybody say hello
hello
how are you hope you're well very well
thank you
uh welcome to Matty welcome to stormy
and welcome to oh so close I'm now damn
it he's over here
uh resident American a young too much
hair American and just Matthew
how are we everybody
we're well
that is excellent so we've had a
slightly big week
if you're starting Star Trek fans no
screw Star Trek if you're Stargate fans
Not screw Star Trek but
if you Star Trek
so we're gonna have a chat about it
let's get into it
[Music]
it's also our Christmas party so I I do
have a beverage
so we will not be live next week we'll
not be live the week after because
that's Christmas Day we probably won't
be live the week after that either
because that's New Year's day but I'm
sure we'll try and get on at some point
over the Christmas period but
if not
merry Christmas everybody Merry
Christmas
Merry Christmas
so before we get into it we obviously
have the slightly exciting news
that I was speaking to one of the people
that I do speak to
um and that actually works in a legal
capacity I can't say much more than that
I can't say Bob shouldn't even say that
but he works in illegal he's a parole
officer go ahead he's my parole officer
because I like to murder Americans it's
the only Americans I'm just liling you
through false sense of security you know
someone's going to send an email right
and then
weekends so it's a hobby
um you're framing us because that means
we're the people that like lure them for
you rumors
[Music]
[Laughter]
of our viewers are Americans so I can't
afford to murder any of you
just for legal purposes I'm joking us
Americans love our murder mysteries
though yeah
so anyway
um I was talking to my colleague and he
has been able to let me know that
actually very early
contractual negotiations have started
with Mark Fergus uh well actually
started with penguin and Parker
um because obviously that's the company
for them to produce Stargate I can also
add a little caveat to that that it is
to produce a movie and a TV series
[Music]
they are negotiating two TV series
not just one so whether that's two
seasons or two different series I'm not
100 uncertain but currently what they're
negotiating is one movie two series
in which order they will then get
released
I cannot be 100 certain but
that's the that's the full disclosure
thoughts
wow that was my thought finally
yes
it's fine it can all go horribly
freaking wrong yeah let's not let's not
kill ourselves all right yeah these are
the early negotiations there's a lot of
contract stuff to go on
um they need to start talking about
budgets and things yeah which is where
I'm told things tend to if they are
going to fall down that's where they
fall down yeah
um so as soon as they start talking
about money
but this is the closest we've got
you know the closest we got before was
Brad Wright wrote a script
oh I can remind me to tell you about
scripts in a second as well
um Brad Wright wrote script he had that
and that's pretty much as far as we've
got MGM did loads of work while they
were stalling basically for Waiting For
Amazon they did quite a lot of work
developing but they never got as far as
anything legal contractual so this is
the furthest we've ever got towards
getting started greens
so other than wow
oh man
well I'd be interested to I guess you
know in terms of the two series
my experience is whenever they say
there's two series it's not too
it's two separate storylines you know
it's like uh lower decks and then it's
uh Brave New worlds it's too serious
it's not one series for two seasons yeah
well I asked Seasons or series
because I know in America they're
different in the UK it's a fuzziness
um
British uh legal area parole officer guy
you were talking to or was he an
American
he's an American no so it's probably two
different
series all together not two seasons we
might get a conclusion to Stargate
Universe that might be a wedding oh my
God
if they're if they're going to do two
series and they've done all this
research they know what we want and that
is one thing Stargate fans want
yeah but Jay you mentioned it was they
might do a little Star Wars the kind of
thing with their shows too so it could
kind of be like a Mandalorian Boba Fett
in a way maybe possibly that's why I'm a
team at the moment but when that's
conjectures and we were seeing him in
that but yeah I think what they've
always said
over the last 12 months I've spoken is
that's what they were looking at like an
intertwined franchise where the series
will not be Standalone they will really
intertwine with each other and but but
yeah I think the Mandalorian book of
Boba Fett and all the other series we're
about to get from Star Wars is the best
way of looking at it I I think that's
where they're going for you've got to
remember
these things haven't decided and the
thing that Mark Fergus is only just come
into this as well so Amazon might go
we're thinking this and Mark Fergus
might go well I'm thinking this
that's a good thing let's do that so I
mean until really they get into the next
bit and Mark Fergus starts to make
decisions now
um
we don't know 100 what we're gonna get
but um
hopefully we get a series called Mal
Durant Ian
right well here you know if they're
going to Star Wars uh model are we ever
going to see a baby Daniel
well we had a baby Yoda
I want to see a baby ancient like hello
fire bug in his little Firefly well I
mean you did just bring up a good point
a lot of shows right now particularly
after like grogu and Star Wars and all
that they want that big merchandise kind
of grab and that big audience people
that don't know and love Star Wars watch
Mando just to watch grogu so what what
baby Asgard it's not very cute though
let's be honest the thing is
fully a fully grown Asgard isn't very
cute but a baby one could be really cute
but it doesn't have to look like a fully
grown as God yeah Babel Evie
babylings that's what we got baby evil
feelings
um by the way guys if you want to
manipulate the conversation please use
the super chats I can't read all the
comments that are coming through but
anyway if you have something you want us
to to read out here's a Super Chat thing
because also I like when it's money it's
Christmas so and if you replicators
they're just like one block aren't they
nice you can't even see and they're just
fall in the other thing
um but right so
um
first of all I mean we've talked about
this a little bit last week but what do
you guys think about there being like a
straight Cinema movie and particularly
as it's getting to the point of
contractually talking about it
um
that means we we're going to be waiting
probably at least another 18 months
mm-hmm I think what I said last week
about them doing a movie is probably the
best thing to do because they're gonna
they can get the excite they can get
excitement from us but they can also get
excitement from the other
demographics you know people are just
like sci-fi people are just like
go into the cinema like Harris for
example he just watches everything
um
diagrams of people interested and and
then when they move on to the show
that's more of an audience so it's not
just going into always a reboot style oh
I can't watch it because I've not seen
the other 10 seasons they can they've
got a jumping off point
yeah yeah
well I think you know um Christian and
Chad was talking about do we think this
is going to be a monster of the week
kind of show more Redline story through
the series
it's
the uh
in terms of historically all the
Stargate shows have been like a um
kind of a monster of the series you know
there's been you know the uh
the replicators for one instance you
know that goes through a whole lot of
series they just don't do pop up and oh
here's a critter let's go to this planet
wipe it out come back pop a beer have a
hot dog you know that's not typically
how we've seen uh Stargate Series in the
past it's been very long Arc stuff very
long stuff and early on in the habit of
being a long Arc story
the last two seasons are basically one
long storyline yeah yeah um but I mean
it started off with major overarching
storylines because obviously the gold I
mean that lasted about five seasons
um so yeah the problem is it's this is
almost certainly going to be unless Mark
Fergus is a freaking genius and pulls
something out of his ass this is going
to be what we used to now and it's going
to be a streaming series 10 maybe 12
episodes
um we still get the network series of
you know like 20 episode series but
they're becoming rarer and rarer you
know it's um
Quality over time it's hard hard fought
to find a good 2022 episode series
nowadays which is kind of odd but it
just is it tends to go CW route now
yep yeah I mean sci-fi series can you
think of any
that run like that man
not even on the Sci-Fi channel or I
can't think of anything
the expanse is like 10 episodes or 12
isn't it yeah
um resident alien
I think that's probably the only one I
can think of they split that series
season two into two I've just started to
watch the second half I think that's
more of a comedy though
still sci-fi some aliens and stuff but
and there is limited special effects but
there are special effects
um I find with like situation comedies
like like resident alien Big Bang Theory
stuff like that they longer Seasons but
actual like proper television doesn't if
you know what I mean like it's not
[ __ ] television but
there's stuff that takes more money
a lot of those have dwindled down to
like 16 or 18 episodes too though
and even the you know some of the more
uh like romantic shows
Virgin River I think is an example I
mean it runs it doesn't run 20 episodes
it runs you know short 10-12 I mean it's
and that's that you know I think we're
uh seeing that that is a trend and it's
here to stay uh I think from a writer's
point of view they kind of like it
because they don't have to fill in a lot
of stuff I remember uh in the last uh
season of Battlestar Galactica the
the more version
um
he said he uh Sci-fi channel truncated
down the last season of it and he says
well it allows us gives us the
opportunity to take a lot of the fluff
that we usually have to do for a 25-24
uh episode season because there's you
have your main story arc but you really
can't fill it up all the way because of
budget constraints so you come up with
these you know small little stories that
have nothing to do with the overarching
thing you forget it the next week so I
guess you know for writer's point of
view you get more concentrated story in
the uh 10 story arcs and you do you know
over double that
just to be that judican thank you
regular uh whole hail the psycho tree
great record in recent days great report
the last year actually I'm just going to
correct you on that one
um we we were first on literally
everything but not the best news I've
seen these because he wants Prada right
which we're going to talk about in a
minute
um not the worst either keep up hard
work hail to all
that's cause they have me on
the episode
um how many we're gonna get
you could potentially longer episodes
than we used to
we might only get 10 or 12 but we'll get
longer episodes so as the standard hour
would have been like what 40 minutes
40 minutes yeah 40 minutes so you might
get an hour but you might even get more
than that like there are certain shows
that are doing way more than an hour
like stranger things like that entire
season I think the longest episode was
like two hours long just one episode it
was like a a movie
so the the
the Prem the the proof is there that it
works because people will sit down to
watch it even if it's on a
condensed episode
like how many you've got I can't I can't
I can't explain that but
we could have longer episodes is what
I'm saying and that's that's interesting
because you can all happen
yeah the two big points about streaming
season series now is what they're
horribly expensive if we look at even 10
episodes if they if they're serious
about this and they're gonna they'll
they would have to try to roughly match
um Star Trek spending
um if they're even remotely serious
about this and that is averaging 10
million dollars an episode so a 10
episode season is still 100 million
dollars still a hell of an investment
you know
um the other thing though about
streaming services is you can drop it
any way you like so exactly with
um strangely worse they wanted to um
sorry with strange things they wanted
that Global episode because it fit the
story you can do that with a streaming
service you can't do that on network
you know it's like so there are
advantages to the streaming model that
we don't get and there's a big thing
within Battlestar Galactica TV series if
ever it gets made the the one guy is the
guy wants to
um
uh he wants to drop three of the
episodes halfway through the season at
the same time because it's a battle
scene but it's going to be from three
different perspectives so it works for
the story to direct those at the same
time and everyone just go crazy I
couldn't hear the smoke alarm Paris
quite well done
did you put out your meth lab fire we
were really concerned yes oh good feel
the floor until it gets hot you're good
all right I thought it might be me
because my smoke alarm went off
literally 10 minutes before we jumped on
here so I'm the actors listening to make
sure it's not mine going off because I
can't hear anything I hadn't heard it
once and then I read that and I heard it
every time
yeah
um Mike has got very goodies but what do
you guys think about that do you are you
are you concerned about it being
streaming or would you actually prefer
it to be Network
yeah
I I even watch you know if I watch like
the NBC Nightly News with Lester Holt
I'll watch it on YouTube I just you know
I
see I wouldn't mind a a combined version
of that I don't know if they could pull
something out like House of the Dragon
does for HBO how it airs at 6 p.m on a
Sunday or or whatever retrospect it is
for y'all
because they they make more money uh
like doing it originally like naturally
not not doing a streaming service uh
because at that point in the UK already
the BBC will add something I'd say six
o'clock it will finish at half six and
then it'll be available when yeah after
that so like you can see our Game of
Thrones the second it airs kind of stuff
I think that would be a good business
model if they can make more money than
just relying on subscribers and new
subscribers coming in because Stargate
will bring a bunch of old the old Garden
like
all of us that are enjoying it but
it's still TBD if it's going to bring a
bunch of new people in hopefully that
movie does the job and is good enough to
bring all the new people in because the
new site uh start date showed will be it
has all of us baked into the audience
already so
hopefully with all that they can get a
good business plan out of it I don't
know on Amazon have loads of options
because they've got loads of platform
options you know they've got MGM plus
they've got free V they've got Amazon
Prime they've got
um something else in America as well
that's MGM owned um they've got they've
got loads of different options
thing
so it's you can watch it for free
and then you can and then if you like it
you can then subscribe to whichever
platform if it's MGM Plus or if it's
Amazon Prime whatever it is
yeah little teaser wet your whistle a
little bit yeah
shall we discuss the bread right thing
so so when I drop this news obviously
I've got loads of comments I've got
loads of comments saying and I got a few
comments saying it won't be Stargate
I've got a few videos coming on with my
opinions of those and I think Shelley
you do too much for us already that's
two three two dollars I'm going to send
you another cup with rude things written
on it but thank you very much in Holiday
Wine holiday beer Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas Shelly
um
so
um I lost my friend I thought
so
right so a lot of the comments was it's
not going to be Stargate because it's
not Brad right done
opinions
well
if anyone has been paying attention to
students that recently Brad Wright did
an AMA on Reddit and he even pointed out
the fact to someone who commented this
very thing that he handed the reins over
to someone else towards the end of sg1
and Atlantis so it wasn't even him in
charge
but you still like Stargate you were
still invested and you still liked it so
it can work you know because he's
already done it it's happened before you
just didn't realize
yeah and my thought with that is
bringing back to Star Wars of course but
when Disney bought Star Wars it wasn't
George Lucas anymore and of course the
quality definitely went down but we had
Dave filoni for all the TV shows and
stuff like that and I think Stargate
needs its Dave filoni now it needs did
Brad Wright have like a
a second hand guy second command kind of
guy that might be able to come in or
anything like that or somebody
Rob Cooper anyone else Pro producer just
to explain I sent Shelly and mug with
them should we spend one step through
the old orifice and I sent that to
somebody that has no interest in
Stargate doesn't have no idea what that
means
um but I did it because it amused me
[Laughter]
um so yeah yeah I I would agree with it
and at the end of the day we know what
Mark Fergus can do I think I honestly
think if you're not going to go Brad
right they weren't the right people
Brad Wright tweeted not long ago though
that he feels there's ageism in his
industry and that um and you know people
wondered did he mean Stargate now that
we know this is the direction it's going
in was he having a little dig
stormy what do you think
maybe I mean why do you come to the old
guy with the Gray beard for the ageism
questions I think it's very ageist of
you
he doesn't know what it means yeah it's
he
I've heard other writers uh especially
in the print industry kind of say the
same and then other writers in the same
industry say no I just got more readers
now
but you know but movies is and TV is a
whole different shebang than you know
actual the uh the the novel in the
printed novel industry
uh I don't know it's um
I do know everybody wants the hot new
thing you know that's a very much a
Hollywood thing Harris
and
but does does it actually seep over to
the writer's room the producer's room
maybe you know
um
you see that a lot with um I just don't
know I mean
Ronald Moore
he I mean you know he's he's an older
guy and he's still cranking out you know
really uh creative series you know I
mean he started with Star Trek next
Generation and worked his way through
and
um I just don't know if uh in the
writer's world now actors yeah
race is an interesting point about it um
everyone wanted the hot new thing so it
might not necessarily be ageism but it
might just be that these particular
writers that are feeling as though it's
ageism just aren't
capable of delivering what new audiences
want they're just stuck in their ways a
little bit maybe that's it's an element
of maybe it's that but maybe it could be
ageism as well I could I could also play
a part but I think that probably plays a
larger part yeah it could be could be I
would just asking like how many
musicians do you know that do their best
stuff in their 60s how many comedians do
you know that get funny as they get
older or I know
saying that Ozzy Osbourne's just
released a new album and it's actually
really good
he's always going to be acceptable 80 or
something yeah so it can be exceptions
to the rule but generally speaking they
seem to do I mean comedians to me is is
one of the is one of the kids I don't
know any comedians that get better
because Billy Connolly is one of my
favorite comedians on the planet
he got into his 50s though he's
not dead George Carlin is dead
um
yeah loose black
George Carlin though did always stay
funny because he just got angry
he said more material we elected more
presidents and he got more material yeah
exactly so there are always exceptions
to the rule but generally speaking I
mean this is I think that could be where
Amazon's coming from or do you just
think they just thought
like they did with Star Trek
we just need somebody new because we
need something that's a bit different
what do you think
I I think it's they just need somebody
new because prime example of all that
not not even I guess making sense in a
film way is just James Cameron right now
anybody betting against him you know
he's and it's what late late 60s maybe
early 70s I'm not positive but
all the reactions as of now is wave
water is 10 times better not ten times
better but it's the story is a lot
better and everything's much better and
if you can improve with age it's like a
glass if I'm lying you know oh and if I
could chime in just one moment we were
about concerning Avatar and its budget
that we spoke about a few weeks ago a
lot of the budget for the next Avatar
movie was also split with some of the
Avatar 3 and Avatar 4. it was yeah so we
really so you know I was I was reading
up on that oh well can we it's it's
almost like he got a coupon to make the
other two
you know so I you know maybe his box
office needs to be a lot less to be
successful because a lot of that
production value
on that point I just don't know why he
said it the way he did
I don't know why he did that because
it's just going to make it look like the
first avatar bombs if it only takes one
and a half billion if it matches
Maverick it looks like it's lost 500
million but you're right it hasn't
so I'm just banging my head against a
woman why did you say that because the
guys
with his comments about hey go pee if
you need to you're gonna watch it again
yeah which I just love the confidence in
that already but think about how many
times people are going to get up to pee
in a three-hour movie about water
I will be three times to pick
um
I'm like I'm thinking I need to go now
but um we all know as soon as I get to
the 60 Minute Mark I start getting a bit
messy
so let me stop talking I need to pee I
should just make watery sounds to what
the Dan's Jay's ears just
how videos do we end with me hitting the
end broadcast button and then me going
every week but you do it at the
beginning as well literally two seconds
before we start
you have the platter of an old lady
and going back to the age do some things
you know it's um
you know I think there's a little bit of
that for Lord of the Rings you know the
power of the Rings
for the rings of power excuse me you
know because they had Peter Jackson you
know the dominating force in the uh in
The Lord of the Rings production and
they said well yeah we're going to have
you know we're definitely going to
consult with Peter
they didn't
you know and I I don't know if it's a
Schism between
uh Prime
you know their production house well no
we don't want him or we want to do
something new and or or it was just he
was the old guy and we wanted new fresh
ideas on a novel that's been oh coming
up on 100 years old
you know it's
having you know at least in terms of the
Rings of power is having New Bright
Ideas behind a book that was printed you
know before most of us were alive
is that a good idea I mean did have did
Jackson actually nail it concerning
bringing it to a visual medium
and uh they poo pooed that because we
want fresh new ideas but yeah with rings
of power though weren't they weren't
legally allowed to talk to Peter Jackson
after a bit they weren't allowed to I
don't I don't believe they the legality
is why they stopped talking to him which
sucks because I would have preferred him
to have a little say but and I don't
like to have the way they approached it
because they just ghosted the guy I know
there's an issue with new line
but not Peter Jackson
you're talking about ghosting him now at
the moment that's what Amazon's done to
Brad Wright yeah
no denying that [ __ ]
that's right I wonder if it's because
they know he is very open he will he's
more than happy to talk to fans and
actually if something was going on maybe
they think he left the bag cat out of
the bag
um but actually
there's an element of that for sure
because he is he's very vocal on Twitter
he knows something's happening he's just
not allowed to tell us so he's not and
he's he's kind of saying certain things
that's that's that's like
uh old man
I was actually told that that's probably
why
um he made his little comment a couple
of weeks ago and and I don't know if I
don't know if he's true or not this is
just this guy's opinion but he made
little comment a couple of weeks ago
about that he doesn't know what's going
on with Amazon anything but he was
trying to maybe separate himself he does
actually know something's coming
but he wants to get away from it because
when it's announced he's going to be
bombarded with with is it you what
you're doing wanting to do it and he
just he doesn't want that so he's sort
of like getting everybody primed now I'm
not involved in this so don't comparing
everyone just by telling them now and
he's going to keep saying it on Reddit
amas and on Twitter and things until
it's announced just this is still going
to be people that message him but if he
hadn't done all of that
he would have been bombarded and also I
mean he might be thinking because he's
not stupid that
he wants Stargate to succeed so he's
prime minister for it he's getting us
ready like I'm not involved in this but
whoever is will do a great job and I'm
behind them 100 but it might or it's
just that he actually honestly has no
clue because Amazon have completely
ghosted him
well he
here's another play on uh remember when
the new Battlestar of Galactica was
coming out and no everyone the fans were
just Off the Wall insane about no no no
no no no no no and so Moore went out and
cast Richard Hatch that was in the
original series and hatch came on said
no this is actually a good thing this is
you know they you know the the younger
the young upstart brought out the old
man to uh Quail the Mad fans and you
know it's
maybe that's rights you know position is
to manage expectations or just you know
to uh provide as a to be a foil for the
whole thing to attract attention as
while they actually get to work and do
their job of making a new Stargate I
don't know
but it's been it's happened before in
terms of the old man syndrome okay is
the perfect option
um penguin and Parker do this so a
production company that have made movies
have made TV shows have experienced this
area they're going to have to have
another partner because they're not
actually on Studios and things there
will be another at least one other
production company involved in this
probably two because I'll probably bring
on a CGI complaint to do that so
um which is still being negotiated as we
say but it's the perfect solution the
Penguin and the park can make this with
all of their experience and they bring
Brad Wright on as a consultant
I think that's what he's trying to do if
he has a an agenda per se
maybe Amazon is kind of holding back on
him obviously it doesn't seem like they
want to use what he has or anything like
that and I think he is trying to stay
active not just to Prime us for a new
Stargate but to Prime himself for a new
job because if if he doesn't end up as
the showrunner or anything like that
which it's not looking like
all of us that have watched our date at
any point are saying well bring him on
as a consultant and it doesn't seem like
Amazon's done that yet but it seems like
he's priming himself to be brought in as
a consultant because that won't be
Amazon's decision that would be Mark
fergus's decision yeah if they've done
all this research they've made a show
like a Content Bible and they've done
all this research to to get Canon
completely right and all this stuff
they've obviously done research online
they they'll know what we want like I
said before so I didn't know they know
we want a conclusion to SGU but they
also know we want Brad right in the in
some capacity and it's not their
decision whether whether he show ones or
not because obviously if they're going
to get the job they've got the job but
they can then go well we can bring him
in and he can he can consult on a little
bit of Canon here and there you can
maybe write a few episodes here and
there and put his name on there in in
big flashing lights so just to appease
appease all of us yeah
feedback on scripts and that was the the
the one more little bit of information I
wanted to give out that apparently there
is a script for at least
um one pilot episode and there is a
outline script for a movie that Mark
Fergus and his team have started to put
together apparently it's not quite
complete but the first drafts of a few
things have started to be done so they
are I mean as far as I'm concerned
that's it's not pre-production as it's
pre-pre-production but those apparently
are done so have a minute
what they're essentially doing is
applying for a job
and the same with Brad he was applying
for a job
going back to what you mentioned about
him uh feeling like he's been ghosted by
Amazon is it really ghosting when
they've said we don't want to go ahead
with your finger now they're
interviewing other people it's not
really ghosting because when you go for
a job interview if you don't get the job
you don't hear from that employer again
either way
it's they've not spoken to him I
actually believe him when he says that
he says it repeatedly and I believe him
I don't think they've ever spoken to him
they had meetings
um I hear they had the last time
and that Brad Wright had meetings it was
with MGM and the final the series hadn't
been finalized and that was the last
time since the since the sale has been
finalized
um there's been no conversation
um that'd be a ghost
pretty shitty yeah
um but the fact that they've got as far
as starting to develop scripts are
starting to do that as well I think is I
mean the thing I like is penguin in a
Parker haven't actually signed in the
dotted line yet but they seem to be
doing a lot of work and it's not just
Mark Fergus it's Haw Coast to be it's a
team there's a there's a quite a big
team there
um they're investing a lot of time in
this if it's not going to happen
yeah
so I think we're going to be reasonably
but um
I mean so no Brad is the one thing I get
let's we'll talk about the dreaded woke
just very briefly
so another comment I get quite a lot
since on that video is that it's going
to be woke garbage so what is the effing
Point um everything's well garbage and
Stargate will be exactly the same
they're just going to kill the franchise
now we know that it's Mark Fergus at
least you know 80 certain or whatever
it's Mark Fergus is there any
any reason to assume that it will be
woke garbage
well I
really so go ahead shut up
stormy shut up Matt
let me go he's on a roll
I hate when people go on about they
haven't seen something and they think
it's going to be woken if it's going to
be all this
crap I hate the word woke in in the
modern sense because that's not what it
originally means whatever that's a
double size point if you haven't seen
something you can't say it's going to be
this it's going to be that
especially if you look at what they've
done before
Iron Man wasn't woke in in what they
deemed to be woke the expanse definitely
isn't woke
I can't remember the children of men
I've not seen but I don't think it was
working from what I've seen aliens too
he wrote Cowboys and Aliens
but none of it feels woke he literally
just writes it as a good story and it
tells it as a good story typically I
think a lot a lot of people use the word
word because they don't want something
to be pushed in there first they don't
want
they don't want it to
take over the story single virtually you
don't want it to be the main thing but I
think a lot of people who use it are
looking for those things if you go into
something looking for those things
you're gonna find it yeah yeah
come on stormy what were you going to
say before uh you know you know I'm
wondering if they're going to keep the
uh the Stargate round because it's
entirely misogynistic
yeah
because it's a hole and they walk
through it
one more go through the old world yes
yes yes
you're all right oh my God Matt's
completely looking back
there's the hole Yeah
I'm getting a bit sweaty oh okay
Saucy
um
I don't know why you have me on here I
really don't because we love you okay
fine what were you saying sorry no that
was that was the only stupid thing I
could come up with when somebody said
woke it was like oh well you know the
gates round so therefore it's massaging
I just I just can't understand why
people would
um yeah this is gonna be crap it's not
even beneficially announced yet
I mean let's at least get it officially
announced
yeah and go ahead
let me just blur it out real quick you
know and the other reason why it's
misogynistic is it you know we call them
Chevrons but we all know that there's
multiple clitor horses on that ring
and we really need to rethink the the
architectural structure of the gate
don't you think Sam because there's way
too much woke [ __ ] but it's it's like a
ladies part so sure that's oh no it's
because it's not um
they'll have to change all the things
um I think Stargate was just like oh
best start you know
stop saying things that are going to
anger people
foreign
if it had come out now people would be
jumping on it saying that's woke because
early on where um there was the
was it Tibetan culture female Jafar
no no no very early on in season one and
it was like the Mongol thing and then oh
episode yeah
they got angry at Sam didn't they and
salmoned up beating the crap out of him
[ __ ] to wear that stupid dress and they
all after
yeah but that that was you know a work
but I I always say like I I I I don't
like the term work I'm with you on that
one Matt um you know I've argued just
loads of times
um there I think there is generally an
issue with some TV series but I think
there always has been
you know it's just the the bad stuff the
stuff that no you know that is like this
and is virtue signal and is trying to
you know being preachy people don't like
it and they don't watch it and we forget
about it
um I want the Whoopi Goldberg movie not
long ago and it was like she was a
lawyer or something or a marketing
person
um and it was actually about female that
nobody would hire her because she was a
woman so she ended up dressing up as a
white guy at the end I don't know what
it's called but I'm just like this is
[ __ ] worker [ __ ] but it was like the
late eighties early 90s
um and I'm like it wasn't even really
about her race it was about what you
know you know the metaphor was you know
across genres but it was really about
being a woman and I'm like those sort of
projects but it's not one of the Whoopi
Goldbergs you could name I can't name it
you know it's not uh what was it was it
one something that crash is my favorite
but uh Rat Race Rat Race there you go so
people have forgotten about it though
because it's not a very good film and it
does preach a bit so people forget about
it propaganda has always been around
but I think we forget about it we've now
got a new word for it and people there
was loads of propaganda in Stargate
because it's just on the back of the
Cold War
yeah they're like the whole Russian
thing everything to do with Russians and
and Jack basically not liking Russians
because of the Cold War
it was full of propaganda well you know
initially Jack didn't exactly like
Carter on his team well it didn't like
Daniel either but you know I don't know
if that's just him wanting only a
military people well no Sam was
definitely military I don't know
in the first season he had personal
issues he says he didn't have an issue
of being a woman he just doesn't like
scientists yeah
but again that whole opening sequence
where Sam has that argument with him and
there's a golden excuse me just because
I rather than the outside
exactly he didn't like scientists
see we need a baby Daniel
but you know what it's like that we're
going to have to put up with that we're
gonna have to put up with people are
going to jump down through us but the
thing that really disappoints me is the
gate is are jumping down and I and I I
honestly think this now really is the
time because we're so damn close to
getting Stargate back there is a lot of
cynicism
in in the in the fan base of Stargate
that they are we've been here before
it's not gonna happen
um and it will happen because Amazon can
make money on it so it will happen
um and you know or it's going to be
rubbish it's not Stargate it's not my
Stargate it's not Brad right and I just
think Now's the Time really guys we've
got to start coming together you know
um
we know that's never going to happen
well here's the thing that you know that
it's my continuing
um complaint about uh troll Tube You
Know The Collector of YouTube that just
is in it for the clicks they they really
don't care about the franchise you know
they will get on and they'll produce you
know one video after another after
another bitching about in this case
Stargate or it was Battlestar Galactica
in the past or as rings of power or hell
it was Lord of the Rings
they just they you know bitching creates
clicks and the more descent you have the
more clicks you get you know and to be
honest Jay I mean this is one of the
more
I mean this channel is one of the more
reasonable ones we actually look at the
art that is created or could be created
and we don't and we don't postulate
about well this is going to be crap
because they hired some writer from I
don't know France
I'm not watching
there's a whole Stargate FR Community we
need them on board
no no again
we had a hundreds years war against the
French at a time where people only lived
to 30 years old
you guys what do we have against friends
it's actually probably Europe's biggest
Stargate Channel
um he's been on this evening he's say hi
everybody
um but um he's fantastic he's one of
stargate's biggest proponents he's he
was really behind the we want Stargate
and bring back Stargate
um big thing a couple of months ago he's
the reason for the hashtag yeah exactly
um it's just the people that live in
France is a problem that's that's all it
is so other than that and absolutely
prefer the only place in France I've
ever been to is Paris and I think even
most of French hate the Brazilians
but anyway I'm only joking for legal
purposes I'm joking
um they're like New Yorkers for y'all uh
which I'll be there in three days okay
so I think I think they're going to
continue the whole hatred against Russia
thing in the new Stargate seeing as you
know Russia is still
you know
that'd be such an interesting story
Putin's currently Waging War against
Ukraine but he also has a Stargate
what's going to happen I think they'll
just ignore it
I'm assuming they'll ignore it it's it's
okay in the Ukraine and that's what he's
after
new series maybe they'll do something
about the pandemic
that would be interesting don't mention
it you know they will Pat damic is a
great time for disclosure so what are
they going to do right in the streets
they're not allowed at the house
came through
it was on some other world where we
visited that was that or had a really
jump species came through the gate
and you know it's it's the prior plague
from season 10. that is literally what
kovid was I saw it I'll tell you what
we're writing the script form
ing I gotta remind you that don't say
the seawood you know that gets us in
trouble oh right let me write that down
you say pandemic no don't say the
seawood uh
I put together a video you're not you're
talking about the five letter c word not
the four letter c word
that's honestly
banned on YouTube so truncate everything
it's got a letter C in it
including cupcake avoid the c word if
you said clitoris earlier as well I
wasn't happy about that it is a problem
well I mean at least it was you know
anatomically correct uh word how do you
feel about Christmas
they're not happy about that either but
because it's Christian in it so it's
like we're supposed to say happy
holidays
we're happy you're
oh I say Merry Christmas because I live
in England and that's that's what we say
winter solstice maybe I wish everybody a
Merry Christmas and I don't really care
yes
um so because you know happy holidays I
don't think we have to remember these
things are words and words I only have
as much power as you give them so can't
tell that to Shakespeare
exactly but anyway so before we move on
to talk about something else you should
totally ruined the show yeah to go back
to Target
um
is there anything that goes to you I
mean obviously because this is like so
we're the closest we've ever got we've
got a showrunner that I think we agree
we all
trust in this one
what are your real hopes for this again
I'll just say this now as well we were
supposed to hear about this in January
was the rumor I've been hearing for the
last three or four months
do you guys think that's even remotely
feasible considering they've only just
started contract negotiations and
um they still don't have a um chief
executive of movies
so as long as they've got to the point
with students
I think it's feasible for them to
announce something not necessarily say
something's coming
on next date but hey we're working on
Stargate that's entirely possible
I mean the closest thing we got to an
official thing over the last 10 years
was when Dean Devlin wrote a limerick
we're going to do the uh Trilogy reboot
for a week that was actually green lit
and that was announced and it still got
canceled
so this could still not happen
because it's happened before
but I am I am I am hopeful and very
excited about it Amazon don't have a
history of announcing stuff and then
it's going backwards so I think there's
too much money on the line for them to
go back on it if they did but yeah
what do you think stormy you think it's
well I I agree with Matt you know uh
Amazon's got way too much money invested
in positive PR
and let's just say they've got financial
problems they don't need extra headaches
because of they shot themselves in the
foot you know they get you know a fan
base all jazzed up about something
that's you know one of their biggest
properties
and they get their fan base all jazzed
up about it then they pull the rug out
from under them well they I mean they've
lost a trillion dollars in valuation
Amazon has and they really can't
they can't afford it you know so I think
they are very very
I mean I think Amazon is very
um
plotting
in strategic of their announcements and
what they release and what they say
corporately you know I mean yeah they
all everybody has all these little back
channels everybody has all these leaks
but in terms of yes we say this is going
to happen
um
I think if some leak you know if some
news ever popped up in The Hollywood
Reporter that Amazon
uh didn't have anything to say about it
wasn't a press release I think the
Amazon would panic because now you know
it's just oh now our reputation's online
and we're skating on thin ice
Amazon has a lot of financial
difficulties right now it's not even
just the financial difficulties they've
got a bad reputation that they're not a
popular company they're a bit like uh
yeah they're almost considered like the
big evil conglomerate because of their
business practices you know and they're
not popular I was told six months ago or
in a year ago that one of the things
they wanted to do is announce these
things really quickly
to get a bit of positive news
um
and it didn't happen because of the
state of MGM and then obvious pandemic
and the economic slowdown they didn't
expect
um even though the idiots if after the
pandemic they didn't expect some of
their value to be wiped out and they're
going to cost a living crisis I just
think
yeah but obviously we weren't expecting
Russia to invade the Ukraine that's good
and I can [ __ ] things up but um you know
there's Amazon really needed a good news
story and they haven't had one
I think it's gonna play out much like it
did with the expanse or so that was
canceled in like what season three 2018
something like that they came along and
they saved it and it was big news for
sci-fi fans they are the heroes that
saved the expanse
if they do the same for Stargate it's
going to be as big if not bigger because
Stargate was a way bigger show than what
the expanse was well I mean Amazon
the the company overall has
um a lot of uh internal problems so just
for transparency I have a cousin that
worked in HR for uh Amazon
um recently laid off but the the uh
things I hear that was going on in
Amazon uh before this rocket job I got I
was considered for Amazon to help run
their drone program drone delivery
program almost almost had the job but
then they quickly canceled it and
there's a lot of things that they've
thrown a lot of cash at that they've
canceled
and they've I mean a lot
I mean just the Drone program the the
money they wasted on coffee in the Drone
program would have funded all you know
five years worth of uh rings of power I
mean it is the the experiments that
they're running in Amazon are insanely
costly
now the the problem is also if you go to
Amazon you you look up stuff brands are
fleeing Amazon like this is the first
year I didn't order anything from Amazon
for Christmas
you know you because you look up well I
need a wrench well you get like a
hundred you know different uh types of
wrenches and they've all got some
strange
you know word in it like d w r q a
that's the brand name and it's all these
Chinese knockoffs that's in invading uh
Amazon as sellers you can't find them
because Amazon FBA becomes such a
massive thing
I'm like Alibaba for Americans yeah and
people selling courses just and then
everyone's like oh I'll jump on that
I'll just get some GP TP whatever from
out from China and sell it as a as a
legit yeah and it's
there's as I understand it from my
inside source it's got laid off it it is
becoming a problem if
Americans are fed on the idea of brand
you want to buy the brand and here you
know here you have a thousand knockoffs
that you know half the reviews are
obviously written by a bot with bad
punctuation rule sets
and so it I don't think it's outside of
the Wheelhouse that Amazon Prime the
studios and the whole streaming business
gets spun off in its own thing
because just to protect it to protect
the whole intellectual print offering
because Amazon
has problems deep seated financial
problems
have deep sea differential problems
Disney does Disney's the one of the
biggest wealthiest countries and they
have deep-seated economic problems
there's some major problems worldwide
with Amazon though they're deep-seated
problems if they decide to separate
the the store with the streaming service
is that in their best interest though
because I feel like a lot of the their
numbers are definitely boosted up by
people that are just members of Amazon
Prime in general that may not even
realize they have the streaming service
they would probably move some of their
other businesses
that are profitable like AWS which is
probably the most profitable really yeah
everything is run on AWS even Netflix
and Disney plus like they probably moved
that away from the Amazon brand or
something
now that gives Amazon an insight into
demographics and things even though
they're not I know they're not legally
allowed to use it but hello
um yeah they're supposed to be uh
Jenny Simon mentioned it it's supposed
to be like some FCC check
fce whatever the acronym is you know due
to due to how costly it is does it
actually get done maybe maybe not no one
actually knows
Prime Flex
he has a uh he has a future in
advertising the crime
Prime Flex plus Netflix brought to you
by Prime
facts because they all boys put a plus
it's Prime flicks with a plus
did you guys hear the the news about uh
uh of Disney's Disney plus new ad
offering and how much money it could
make them a year
just by offering a free service for that
I know it was with a B three
billion dollars a year without Revenue
Netflix about to do the same Netflix are
about to have an option for cheaper so
it'll be like five bucks rather than ten
and but you have to have adverts and
they yeah their lowest paid plan yeah
it's ad supported I think I'm on that
one at the moment and I don't really
want to spend the extra 10 pound but I
don't want adverts I'm gonna have to
yeah
um not extra 10 pound extra four pound
to make it 10 pounds
but um but yeah let's see and one thing
is right so easy ways to make the fans
happy when Stargate does return
um
bring in a star from the original series
is the easiest thing for them to do I
just want Jackson to know your interest
in who you would like them to bring in
because you know we're slips for that
sort of thing they will bring in
he's a Judas
ended
how about you guys what do you think if
you had to pick one
well it either you know I'm kind of torn
I I'd like to see you know
um
well we already kind of know TLC's
origin story but I really like to see
what he's been up to in the last you
know decade or so tilk story would be
cool uh but yeah you gotta have you
gotta have Dr Daniel Jackson you know
I will I will say there was um
I think they really
I can't remember which episode this was
I I it um
it was where Jackson was uh
what was he was on a roof and he was
like you know uh spotting for snipers or
something and uh yeah he uh he was
looking uh it was an episode of snug at
Universe no yeah and and they were
trying to you know track the uh illusion
so it's a dilution Alliance I think
and Jackson I mean that was just so out
of character for him to have the
spotting scope on the roof and calling
in it's just that wasn't not that really
it's stuck in my mind and it's like
that's not doctor
I think that was the Natural Evolution
of Daniel to be honest because he was a
nerdy guy who ended up being given a gun
it went through all this this pain it
become like an Indiana Jones
archaeologist
now now is like Secret Service kind of
thing because he's like
not going through the gate as much
that's I think that's a natural
evolution
David sir him being space Indiana Jones
would be fantastic in my book but I I
don't I don't necessarily love the hyper
militaristic Daniel Jackson I don't know
if I've even made it there yet but
start
I don't think you'd ever be uh
militaristic is always going to be that
um
that civilian who who looks at the
military fondly but he he doesn't think
they how they think okay good
to be great I can't believe nobody's
mentioned Richard Dean Anderson though
we don't see Richard nanson come back in
any even for a little bit I'd love to
but that guy has to do a half a year I
mean just he needs to get back in shape
it's just a plain way to put it and I
don't know
oh that's right
yeah he's lost his load away um they
want that was the rumor actually that he
was losing weight because back before
the sale was finalized MGM like as black
with 700 MGM thought they were going to
be allowed to just crack on the Stargate
and Brad Wright was talking to Amanda
Tapping Daniel Shanks and RDA
we know from that meeting the other day
that um at least one of Brad writes we
know that Richard Dean Anderson and
Amanda Chapman were going to be in the
pilot script because at one point
O'Neill says to um Carter that I've
still got your toothbrush
and that was the line that Brad Wright
said as said that there's was in the
script
um so we look at so that was the rumor
that he was losing weight because he was
going to be on and they were expecting
to have been filmed by now they were
expecting to you know be honest Greens
in Spring
um until ham until Amazon went no not
happening
um but yeah I think I'd love to see
Amanda tap and come back but I'd love to
see it like as a small part the way she
directs and stuff as well and I think
that would be really great
um but you'd say the characters that I
can see coming back definitely
um Daniel Jackson because it makes sense
I'd love to see him as sort of like a
civilian leader of the Stargate command
now which is there we go but homework
into something yeah oh exactly yeah
um Sam Carter's an easy one to come back
but I actually agree with you guys teok
is the easiest
because yeah you know we desperately
want to see because the Jaffa
if Mark Ferguson anywhere else has got
any sort of sense the jaffa's a big part
of this and where the Jaffer are now is
a big part of it but again if he was the
leader of the new Jaffa the free free
Jaffa he would be again a part that
could come in and out really really
easily yeah
and you can bring in a whole new
audience as well because he's been God
of he's been playing God of War since
2018. and he's just won an award for it
and he's he's like well in the news and
everything right now is in the Limelight
if they announced something and he was
involved that audience would want to see
he's kind of been campaign
played live action Kratos as well so
he's got like a social media presence
and everything right now he would be
kind of that guy to just shoehorn back
into a new series some some way
he went from killing Gods on Stargate to
killing gods in God of War
will the new series be in a pre-stargate
disclosure world or post disclosure
we'll we'll at some point will the event
of exposing the Stargate program to all
of humanity
here on Earth will that be a thing
that's happened in the past where that
should be something to work up to or is
it just going to be a business as usual
keep the you know keep everybody in the
dark
I feel like that'd be an awesome season
one plot device and have that informed
in season one and
something will have to happen yeah
they'll be an enemy or something and
we'll have to disclose it for whatever
reason and that is season one or maybe
the first half of season one
I I think it's too complicated to not do
it that way I think if it's already been
disclosed you've got so much that you've
got to explain yeah yeah yeah yeah and
the only way to do that is in our little
Stargate SGC series we did we basically
said the first series was about catching
us up
and that's what there's 15 years of
stuff that's happened we need to catch
up and that's what the first season
would be about
and then we said that but another way of
doing it is with flashbacks yeah yeah
you have to build something to the story
so you start off where we are and
there's been disclosure but you've got
to go back and explain it
at some point
the easier and less messy way of doing
it
is like you said stormy that things are
a business as usual and something
happens
the furlings attack there we go done
you're never going to let this one go is
he
um
the the documentary in sg1 I forget
which one of the later Seasons where
they filmed the documentary
God that would be you know that gets
leaked or something you know and by the
New York Times or something and yeah you
know going back to I don't want to see a
wimpy Stargate
and Jason there's been quite a few
instances of uh the Stargate like base
is being filmed isn't there the episode
of Heroes like you've just mentioned and
then there was the Prometheus project
they literally had a film grew on but
then they they got kidnapped
so I don't know what happened to the
tapes there maybe they got flushed out
but
there was quite a lot of opportunities
as you say for things to get leaked
especially in today's age with the
internet because that wasn't really a
thing about them
and they could just show one of the
video at that point they have videos to
show the public so
they could explain it away like that but
it's CTI it's faked that's the easy way
dude
oh yeah it got leaked on Twitter in uh
in 2011. it's just just what happened
on another series of Wormhole extreme
just to distract people
um but yeah that's um I mean I like the
New York Times idea because obviously
they're the ones that leaked the or put
out the story initially about like the
um all those UFOs and the uh you know
the Speedster and all that sort of thing
so it's sort of like mirror what
actually happened during covid but then
that would have to be
flashback so I mean one way of doing it
is that like you said they
it was released and became public
knowledge during lockdown and no one
really noticed
is is one way didn't you know they know
I'm still waiting for the New York Times
to do a follow-up story well these ships
that they come from you know not of this
world what kind of ships are they and
what's the biological presence on such
world where do we theorize it this world
is that I mean there is a well you and
I've met discuss you know on YouTube
kind of discussing the the things that
the New York Times just failed to follow
up on
yeah I mean how many thousands of views
did we get off the air disclosure videos
just based on oh [ __ ] you know they've
admitted it and nobody cares yeah
maybe the way they do it maybe it's been
semi-exposed
they were
um they just put the Flies down sort of
thing but maybe it's been like people
kind of know about the Stargate but they
don't really know what it is and they
don't obviously don't know all the other
stuff
about the Jaffer so it's kind of like MK
Ultra we know it happened we just don't
the most people don't really know what
it's about yeah yeah exactly yeah so so
it's like people like us who who would
look at that stuff we know about it but
like yes my mum for example she like
doesn't know that is
well I'm kind of I'm kind of shocked how
many people don't know how many Rocky
companies there are I mean they don't
know what SpaceX is they don't know what
Virgin Galactic is they don't know what
blue origin is so somebody went to space
we went to there's a lot more than that
too
yeah
blue origin song with a penis [ __ ]
rocket right yeah that's right yeah it's
the vibrator with a with uh fins massive
engine on the bottom
but uh Jamie you mentioned flashbacks a
minute ago and that made me think
could they set themselves up by doing
something similar to House of the Dragon
in season one with all the time jumps
and do a couple time Jump episodes but
have different aged casts
and have at that point you could fill in
a series you know between those time
jumps and those could be spin-off series
that they're setting themselves up for
in the future
I hope they don't do that in a way
because Stargate was always done like it
could be happening now yeah yeah and I
kind of hope they can continue along
that thinking but really
like we said earlier we have no idea
what they're going to do they could
really do anything and because we don't
know and and one thing I gotta say I
I I've noticed a couple of comments
about Mark Fergus in the in the comments
um about that we have some maybe some
concerns about working outfits I I
personally don't but if there are
concerns
one of the concerns is if you the the
main thing I know about Mark Fergus
um in his writing in particular is based
on the expanse the expanse was based on
a series of novels so he took those
novels and turned them into a TV series
he didn't actually like with Hawk Osby
as well but he didn't actually have to
create anything new
yeah Stargate he's having to create
something new
Iron Man based on a novel yeah based on
Comics obviously Children of the um
Children of Men was based on a novel
um you know it goes so has he actually
got a history of creating anything new
and in that case should we a bit be a
bit concerned
we can argue that's exactly the same
because he's got 17 Seasons to draw
inspiration from
and what did you say sorry Harris as
Cowboys and Aliens a novel it was a
comic book wasn't it comic book okay
okay well then yeah
same question
these days comes from comic books yeah
and and I made a good point Matt made a
good point that saying he has got 17
years of Canada as long as he sticks to
Canon
um but again he's got free reign
now my understanding and he's been told
when he was doing this
um content Bible he was told very
clearly what he was allowed and what he
wasn't allowed to mess with and that was
a a two-way negotiation though there was
there was a negotiation that went on
um Amazon like we don't really want you
to do that we want you to put that con
folks on this and Mark it was like I
think from a story point of view you
know I mean there was a two-way
conversation
but
I'm not really worried about that
because I think Mark Fergus is
definitely one of those people that
would stick to Canon he really stuck to
the novels of the expanse and I know he
was only involved very heavily involved
in the first four seasons but
um he they stuck to the novel they
adapted it really quite Faithfully
but made it into a TV series that's
excellent
but he hasn't maybe done anything that's
completely
free reign before
should we be a bit worried about that
nah I think it's like excitement and
terrified all at once but you gotta just
hope for the best at that point yeah I
agree right well guys thank you so much
I I'm gonna have to call it a day
because I promised my wife
okay no I don't need anymore
um
I I did promise I'd be off by about ten
by six gotta get cooked in it but
um so because we're going on holiday
tomorrow it's our last evening with the
kids so we've promised
um guys thank you so much again and I
just want to just just very quickly
while you guys are here I've just done a
video thanking the three of you for
everything you've done four Stargate in
the last 12 months I mean 12 months ago
I didn't even know who the hell you were
I was going through videos today and you
kept popping up in the comments I was
like I don't know it was then
and store me all year man you've been in
even when you are knackered even when
you've been working hard you still
dragged your Danny DeVito ass on the
screen which is just a thingy and um
Paris
didn't know who Harris was even like six
months ago yeah I
know Harris is Gee
Gees trousers are on fire
um
but guys yes I think your blood's on
fire yeah but it's awesome guys it's
been an amazing 2022 thank you so so
much thanks Jack guys thank you Shelly
thank you Andrew yeah thank you
everybody in there and yeah just guys
keep on going and let's let's look
forward to 2023 when we're actually
going to have Amazon stores talk about
hey guys when we come back in the New
Year we might have something official to
talk about so that'd be great if
something official comes up in between
now and New Year we have to go live
the water releases in in very short
period of time we will talk about it
next time but guys thank you so so much
have a merry merry Christmas everybody
too happy holidays bye say bye then bye
I can't do the normal thing I've got to
try and find the outro normal thing
never find the outro found it
[Music]